[Musique]
j'attends qu'on me propose de tourner
dans un film pornographique
attention quand je dis film
pornographique chez moi être acteur
parlant dans un film pornographique il
ya toujours des seconds rôles des fois
dans les belles productions des gens qui
sont en fonte ou qui annonce quelques
informations avant que la scène démarre
c'est souvent ces passages qui sont les
plus intéressantes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis sans réfléchir mais non je hais
ce que je briserai dans 40 personnes
pour ensuite tout le film soit vu par
plusieurs centaines de mille personnes
ont totalement seul c'était vraiment
c'était une découverte assez solitaire
et très vite après ça a été partagé avec
des camarades break quand tu es jeune
ado tu tu cherches un peu donc avec les
copains dit qu'est ce qui se passe tak
tak bon bref j'espère que j'espère que
tous ont fait genre de fautes parce que
sinon je vais en passer pour un con en
plein de mecs un peu pervers je suis à
fond sur les trucs de vieux tout ce qui
est vieux maroquinerie dès que je peux
avoir un vieux avec la maroquinerie là
je pars
[Musique]
sourire tout de suite tout de suite
sourire fascination interdite il y avait
une forme de mystère en tout cas c'est
pour moi ça s'est terminé mission qui me
fascine parce que le tout milieu du pont
c'était totalement mystérieux et hyper
opaque
ce que je trouve vraiment transgressif
ce serait une vraie forme d'abandon
d'entre les partenaires et devrait
plaisir ce serait un peu gênant pour le
coup parce qu'on aurait vraiment
l'impression de rentrer dans une forme
d'intimité réel entre deux personnes
pas simplement physiquement des mecs ou
des meufs qui baise arrêtons les villas
de luxe comparé des viaducs tout à
l'heure arrêtons trop de villas de luxe
de canapé en skaï
il faut changer au niveau des décors
surprenez-nous quoi surprenez
nous un peu enfin quelque chose de jeu
voilà gravity quoi voilà dans l'espace
là tu voyages et puis imagine
possibilités physiques du vol dans
l'espace je sais pas ce qui se passe je
suis tu arrives pas tu te pointes
bidouille ça c'est fou ça c'est
d'ailleurs là que tu vois